[Music]
this episode is brought to you by viori
clothing spelled v-u-o-r-i
viori i've been wearing vyori at least
one item per day for the last few months
and
you can use it for everything it's
performance apparel but it can be used
for working out it can be used for going
out to dinner at least in my case i feel
very comfortable with it super
comfortable super stylish and i just
want to read something that one of my
employees said she is an athlete she is
quite technical although she would never
say that i asked her if she had ever
used or heard of vyori and this was her
response i do love their stuff been
using them for about a year i think i
found them at rei first for my partner
t-shirts that are super soft but somehow
last as he's hard on stuff and then i
got into the super soft cotton yoga
pants and jogger sweatpants i live in
them and they too have lasted they're
stylish enough i can wear them out and
about the material is just super soft
and durable i just got their clementine
running shorts for summer and love them
the brand seems pretty popular
constantly sold out in closing and i'm
abbreviating here but in closing with
the exception of when i need technical
outdoor gear they're the only brand i've
bought in the last year or so for yoga
running loungewear that lasts and that i
think look good also
i like the discrete logo so that gives
you some idea that was not intended for
the sponsor read that was just her
response via text viori again spelled
v-u-o-r-i
is designed for maximum comfort and
versatility you can wear it running you
can wear their stuff training doing yoga
lounging weekend errands or in my case
again going out to dinner it really
doesn't matter what you're doing their
clothing is so comfortable
and
looks so good and it's it's
non-offensive that you don't have a huge
brand logo on your face you'll just want
to be in them all the time and my
girlfriend and i have been wearing them
for the last few months they're men's
core short kore the most comfortable
lined athletic short is your one short
for every sport i've been using it for
kettlebell swings for runs you name it
the banks short this is their go to land
to sea short is the ultimate in
versatility it's made from recycled
plastic bottles and what i'm wearing
right now which i had to pick one to
recommend to folks out there or at least
to men out there is the ponto
performance pant and you'll find these
at the link i'm going to give you guys
you can check out what i'm talking about
but i'm wearing them right now they're
thin performance sweatpants but that
doesn't do them justice so you gotta
check it out ponto ponto performance
pant for you ladies the women's
performance jogger is the softest jogger
you'll ever own
viori isn't just an investment in your
clothing it's an investment in your
happiness and for you my dear listeners
they're offering 20 off your first
purchase so get yourself some of the
most comfortable and versatile clothing
on the planet
it's super popular a lot of my friends
have now noticed are wearing this
and so am i viori clothing dot com
forward slash tim that's v u o r i
clothing dot com slash tim not only will
you receive 20 off your first purchase
but you'll also enjoy free shipping on
any us orders over 75
and free returns so check it out viori
clothing dot com slash tim that's
v-u-o-r-i clothing dot com slash tim and
discover the versatility of the ore
clothing
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement i've been asked this for
years the answer is invariably ag-1 by
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance so you can cover
your bases if you're traveling if you're
just busy if you're not sure if your
meals are where they should be it covers
your bases i've recommended it
since the four hour body which was god
eons ago 2010 and i did not get paid to
do so with approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods source
ingredients you'll be hard-pressed to
find a more nutrient-dense formula on
the market it has a multivitamin
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes and
adaptogens
you get the idea it is very very
comprehensive and i do my best of course
to focus on nutrient-dense proper meals
but sometimes you're busy sometimes
you're traveling sometimes you just want
to make sure
that you are getting what you need ag-1
makes it easy to get a lot of nutrition
when whole foods aren't readily
available it's also nsf certified for
sport making it safe for competitive
athletes as what's on the label is in
the powder it's the ultimate all-in-one
nutritional supplement bundle in one
easy scoop right now athletic greens is
giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
tim
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can i answer your personal
questions
[Music]
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show where it
is my job to deconstruct world-class
performers to tease out the routines
habits etc that you can apply to your
own lives this episode's going to be a
little bit different in this episode
past podcast guest
and excellent writer cal newport
interviews me for an article he ended up
writing for the new yorker titled
revisiting the four-hour work week how
tim ferriss's 2007 manifesto anticipated
our current moment of professional
upheaval so the call itself was
for material we were having a
conversation for this print piece that
ended up coming out and i really enjoyed
the conversation and thought you might
as well so who is cal cal newport you
can find him at
calnewport.com c-a-l-n-e-w-p-o-r-t.com
is an associate professor of computer
science at georgetown university who
previously earned his phd from mit his
scholarship focuses on the theory of
distributed systems while his general
audience writing explores intersections
of culture and technology cal is the
author of seven books including most
recently deep work digital minimalism
and a world without email he is also a
contributing writer for the new yorker
and the host of the deep questions
podcast you can find my interview with
cal me interviewing him that is at tim
dot blog slash cal newport and you can
find the 2007 talk at south by southwest
that launched everything so my talk at
that festival my first ever keynote on
the content and the concepts in the
four-hour work week at team.blog
sxsw and with all that said please enjoy
tim thanks for taking some time to talk
with me today
my pleasure
excited to dig in yeah so i really want
to focus you know as we've talked about
before
on
the conception and immediate reception
of the four-hour work week and just to
remind you of the context i'm interested
in this idea that
that book's reception in 2007 was
actually a
warning shot of sorts about what was
happening in the world of work
becoming less sustainable and it was a a
warning shot that was largely forgotten
and now we are feeling it today the
after effects of this thing that you
were pointing out early so i wanted to
get into a little bit of story of the
book and the reception i'm going to ask
you about that
and get your thoughts about why in some
sense that warning shot
faded out of people's perception for a
while so that's the route i'm going to
take if that's a minimal to you
that's absolutely amenable i'm i'm game
all right so look i want to set the
context of the times and the culture
before you started conceiving this book
so
right off the bat you graduated
princeton do i have this right right
around two thousand what was the actual
year you graduated
exactly two thousand okay and did you go
straight from princeton to trusan was
that your first job i did i did
okay yep had the desk in the fire exit
very much not up to code
they were over over capacity so it was
an exciting time to get land in silicon
valley
and you were there for that first crash
the 2001
yes absolutely absolutely so when did
you begin
to notice
signs of unsustainability
about the the work culture out there was
it true san was it later with your
startup and what was it like out there
because and just this context this 2000
to 2005 roughly this is when as far as i
can tell
something tipped in the culture
especially in silicon valley towards
this sort of hyper commutative
unsustainable so i know somewhere around
there this was happening you were there
what were you seeing on the ground back
then i was seeing what i suppose
many people were seeing and engaging in
which is a
heroic sprint or what was intended to
hopefully be a sprint to
sort of cash in or cash out with these
incredibly fast growing startups this
was
the sort of new new economy all the
rules were thrown out at least that's
how it was presented in the media
and i think everyone there was inclined
to believe it because it was a
an appealing fiction
that you could sprint for a few years
and everyone could make a ton of money
and
cash out
turns out that is harder to do
than it would seem on paper but when
things crashed at least what i saw
before
the tech startup implosion
was people coming into the office on
the day before thanksgiving or
thanksgiving and working late into the
night and so on and that in and of
itself is not
intrinsically unsustainable for everyone
but it's unsustainable for a lot of
people right if you're ruth bader
ginsburg yes you can do that for the
entirety of your whole life if you're
henry kissinger you can also do that
but i think the vast majority of us
can't sustain that for an incredibly
long period of time so i took the
behaviors
that i had
developed working in the startup culture
working in a very fast-growing startup
and then applied it to my own business
starting around
say 2001 my tenure true sand didn't last
very long because true sand didn't last
very long
and
i was
working across multiple time zones i was
waking up early going to bed
very very late and
probably clocking i would say at least
12 hour days typically and
what i began to notice this is very
early from a tech perspective right if
you wanted to access
certain
say files on your computer this is
pre-dropbox you might have to use
something like go to my pc to log in
remotely and so on so as far as mobility
and remote access it was very very early
days we had flintstones tools at the
time
compared to today
but
the
breaking point for me was about 2004
and
i was dating a wonderful girl who i
thought was probably going to end up my
wife and she broke up with me and gave
me a not exactly a plaque but do you
know those trifold
photo holders that you get at a target
or something like that there's a wire
brushed and so on and so she had created
a collage of sorts it showed me
photograph of my head cut out and pasted
onto this
paper body in a business suit with a
briefcase with stuff flying out and it
said business hours end at 5 pm and so
she basically said keep this for your
health put this on your desk and
at the end of that relationship
what i
realized was that outside of the pre
startup crash
euphoria and the quick flips and so on
if i telescoped out
and if i'm not really getting to your
answer tell me but this is sort of a
microcosm of the macrocosm if that makes
sense
if i telescoped out a year five years
ten years
and looked at the behaviors they were
not sustainable and the problems that
were small were going to get bigger the
little
physical issues that i had from sitting
in front of computer for those types of
stretches were just going to compound
so on and so forth and so that is when i
decided to either completely rethink and
remake the business or shut it down and
that led to
a
commitment to back when you could buy a
one-way ticket overseas without too much
trouble i bought a one-way ticket to the
uk where i stayed with a college friend
crashed on a couch and i committed to
spend four weeks there to figure things
out and
ultimately even with the rudimentary
tools at the time was able to really
automate
and outsource an incredible amount
at the time using things like elance and
again remote access tools like go to my
pc where you would still have to go to
an internet cafe mind you
i guess it was easy internet or easy
cafe which was the internet cafe
equivalent or
cousin of easyjet if that rings any
bells and
i just continued traveling because i had
sort of
removed the need to be physically in one
location
and
that
led me to travel around the world for
around a year
and
over that period of time
was guessed and i'll stop in a minute
because i'm not sure if i'm going in the
right direction but over that time and
for actually many years prior from 2000
was the date i want to say it was 2003
to 2013. i guess lectured at princeton
twice a year in high-tech
entrepreneurship class
and i was the bootstrap example they had
a lot of venture-backed
entrepreneurs who would come speak to
the class and i was the bootstrapping
example
and i began to
sort of codify the rules that i had
borrowed or refined for myself in this
huge experiment
and that much later turned into the
four-hour work week
just that by the way as an aside
where was the there's not a business
school at princeton so who where were
they hiding this high-tech
entrepreneurship class i'm assuming it
was probably phenomenally popular
it was very popular and
relatively new all things considered it
was in the
it was in two departments it was ele 491
so it was in electrical engineering and
even though it was
decidedly
non-technical it was within electrical
engineering and also i believe it was
called it may have changed in name orf
operations research finance like
financial engineering and operations
engineering so i believe it straddled
both of those departments and so you had
undergrads and graduate students in that
class and it was phenomenally popular
the professor ed shao z s c h a u
is
an incredible
human incredible teacher incredible
character he's worth looking up i don't
know how much you want me to get into
right now but he was a former
competitive figure skater had been a
congressman had taken a couple of
companies public was one of the first
computer science teachers at stanford
had then taught at harvard business
school of course chronologically all
these things are out of order
and
he was tremendously
inspiring and also encouraging and so he
helped connect me
ultimately with the people who led to
the job at true zone
and was he ed was who taught you the
pareto principle do i have that right
it's a good question i'm not sure if ed
taught me pareto's principle the pareto
principle could also have come from a
lot of reading i mean i've always been a
voracious reader so it could have come
from any number someone you cited yeah
in your 2007 speech maybe it was a
different ed was there an ed lao is that
is there a different i'm trying to
or ted
if i had mentioned
an ed it probably would be ed shell
so i'm perfectly happy to attribute it
to ed
we'll get we'll give him the credit
rewinding just a little bit though so
i like this idea that you have this you
know
the new new thing
culture
in silicon valley late 90s early 2000s
everyone wants the jim clark hyperion
yacht you know this is where i'm gonna
end up right and so you know you go and
you you go to your startup this is how
i'm gonna push now because that's what
you do
now in your case you mentioned somewhere
i think maybe in the four hour work week
which i just i reread last weekend oh
thanks for that you mentioned
cryptically
well it's great i love the book and i
still remember my first listening of it
after our common friend ramit sethi
called me was like my friend tim has
this book you got to read it today and i
i listened to it on audible or whatever
it was back then ray porter good
narrator yeah ray porter is great yeah
he does a lot of thrillers now too
yeah he's perfect
you mentioned
you mentioned the book that you had made
a fatal flaw
with your company that meant that you
weren't going to
this wasn't something you're going to
sell in three years and buy the yacht
a little bit of a side i'm just curious
what was the fatal flaw that made the
the company something that wasn't going
to be quickly sold well i think that if
you start with the end in mind perhaps
i'd started with the wrong end and by
that i mean
my
relationships and contracts and so on
would not
necessarily transfer over to new
leadership so a lot of the business was
dependent on me ultimately i created the
business because i understood
that
i had a very large margin of safety with
the actual profit margin
and it was also an area i understood
really well but the the flaw was not i
mean there are many there was more than
one flaw is the short answer
but there's a good book actually that
people can read which gives them pretty
much the gist in the title and that is
built to sell
and
a more extreme example of something not
built to sell would be say the tim
ferriss show the podcast right it is so
intrinsically
intertwined with me there's a key man in
this case dependency there's a bunch of
that built into the business
and
that made it
more
difficult the other piece that made it
difficult in a sense which can be a very
elegant solution for
you know hesitate to call it a lifestyle
business because some of these so-called
lifestyle businesses are really just
cash flow
healthy businesses that are privately
held right i think they get maybe an
unfair knock but
with many of these lifestyle businesses
certainly a lot of the businesses that
exist now and a lot of the businesses
that were created after people read the
four-hour workweek
you would have one or two
owners
and then you would have
lots of contractors
and
if you haven't assembled a management
team that would
effectively transfer as an aqua hire
even if the price were larger to another
company there are all sorts of
complexities involved so
that's a bit of a meandering answer but
there are a bunch of weaknesses because
i created it first and foremost
having never sold a company having never
invested in startups having never even
really considered how one would build a
company to sell i started it first and
foremost to produce
cash flow and
that's the
long and short answer
right exactly that in some sense because
you've mentioned before for example at
some point people tried to knock it off
unsuccessfully and that's because it's
not just the idea or assembling the
right contractors
it's the intense focus on operations
that the
founder runner you injects into it that
i am here seven a.m to midnight doing
all the things keeping the things up
caring you are the operational cog
yeah yeah absolutely you can hire all
the contractors and set up a
relationship with a manufacturer but if
you're not paying attention to it cal
may i add actually one more thing yeah
sure of course i was just gonna say i
think it's important to note that
because we're talking about sprints and
i mentioned that word at least and
sustainability and so on i think it is
all things equal critically important if
you are opting into say the venture
backed startup game where there are some
zero-sum scenarios that you work your
ass off i do actually think that's
important if you're playing that game
and
it is in some ways very similar to
professional sports it tends to favor
the young who are really going to put
nose to grindstone and are willing to
engage in that type of full contact
sport
but even
within that type of intense environment
things very often take two or three
times longer than you would like them to
and cost two or three times more so
it makes sense to have systems and
habits and principles that support those
types of contingency plans if that makes
any sense
well yeah and i'm glad you brought that
up because this sort of brings me to my
my next question which is
do you have this culture emerging in
silicon valley where there's people
making a run for
startups that going big for the first
time this capital was there everyone saw
what happened to netscape and then the
firing gun had had been fired but then
what interests me is where i don't know
if you have an answer or not
is that attitude
metastasized out of people who were
employing number three on a startup
trying to hit an ipo schedule and it
grew to just
i'm a programmer i'm in the marketing
department at this larger company and
then it grew out of silicon valley and
the knowledge worked more generally this
let's get after it let's sprint this
this hustle culture and the other place
it has shown up where it was sort of
necessary was in you know high finance
so in the 80s i guess you had michael
lewis now for him looking at silicon
valley of course he had liars poker so
you they also was that culture was
coming out of the managing director push
in high finance in the 80s and 90s and
then we get this push for your startups
but it spread
and it spread to people who
i am not in line to i don't own 30 of a
company that my efforts going towards
that i'm gonna make a lot of money when
this thing sells and yet everyone began
working more and more like that verified
model of the founder trying to make
their startup successful i don't have an
answer i don't have an answer but i
don't know if you have a thought on it
but why
is this just silicon valley's cultural
influence because this is what i saw
that idea spread and people began
treating work became more and more that
type of sprint even when there wasn't a
clear finish line that you were
sprinting towards it's a good question
and i can only
take uh an educated stab at it
but it's still speculative i would say
i think what happens in silicon valley
often
is twofold there are
companies and people who are lionized
and
put on a pedestal and therefore
culturally
there is a lot of
imitation of silicon valley
i do think that's a piece i do think
though it's possible that an even
larger piece is that
silicon valley certainly
at that time and there are more
places like silicon valley now whether
that's new york city cambridge shanghai
beijing there are more places like it
but if we flash back to
the early 2000s silicon valley was also
the prototyping and testing ground for
new technologies and you had
bleeding edge early adopters
even if technologies are available
you know i think of the
william gibson quote which is very
overused but it is apt here which is the
future is already here it's just not
very evenly distributed and that's true
in
silicon valley so for instance years ago
you could go into a coffee shop in
palo alto and they were actually
attempting i think it was koopa cafe
c-o-u-p-a they were attempting to allow
you to pay in bitcoin
for
your coffee i don't think they had many
takers but nonetheless that was an
option and similarly i think whether
it's internet cafes remote work
arrangements
virtual organizations a lot of these
were tested early on and you also had
people buying tools and
iphones and so on all the iphone may
have come later with a certain density
in silicon valley and when you have all
of those tools and you have certain
cultural norms but they're enabled by a
certain pervasive technology fetish
if we look at where we are now it's
easiest way to make the point that
when you can always be connected
and when you don't have a single
physical office
you can work all the time
and in fact it's incredibly challenging
and you need
strategies and rules
maybe even
technological
constraints so that you don't work all
the time it bleeds over
and i think that's a byproduct of not
just the culture and the narrative
although that's a big piece of it it's
also byproduct of
silicon valley at the time at least
being sort of ground zero for density of
new tech use which then proliferated out
to other places
i like this because i think it's the
alternate
hypothesis and it's a hobby horse
hypothesis of mine that the other way to
understand
people getting
more busy work seeming less sustainable
we have my original hypothesis which is
there's this culture of overwork that
came out of silicon valley but what
you're saying here is the other i think
competing hypothesis which is maybe even
more right i mean i just wrote a whole
book about this it was the tools yeah
and that when you give people always on
low friction digital communication
there's weird dynamics that occur and i
note for example
in your 2007 sort of coming out south by
southwest talk south by southwest
interactive talks i want to get to is
sort of the core of this book's release
and i just re-listened to it
email is mentioned you mentioned email
four times in the first six minutes of
that talk it is your personification in
some sense of unsustainable work right
the whole opening of this talk is about
how work has become unsustainable and
email is brought up multiple times as
the example so this is the competing
hypothesis which is once email
spread and again we can blame silicon
valley in the sense that they probably
prototyped like hey we should all be on
email talking all the time and that's
where that came from it became an
accidental byproduct we can all reach
each other at all times there's no
governor on that behavior and the whole
social
cultural economic business culture
environment just spiraled out of control
and suddenly no one knew what to do we
were constantly getting emails we didn't
know what to do with it no one was
putting a tap on that no one was asking
how should we do it so that's that's
another hypothesis that maybe that one's
more accurate how did you because you
mentioned email so much when you were
talking about this book in the time
i'm taking it that's an important to you
that's an important piece of part of
what was making work less sustainable
back then oh for sure and i mean i think
that well a few things number one i
would love to hear that talk because i
haven't heard it since i gave it i
wasn't even aware that they had a
recording so if you could send a link to
that i would love to
to listen to it i have to remember your
powerpoint broke do you remember that i
do remember that i absolutely remember
that i do remember it seemed like a
metaphor for something it seemed very
profound it was very
very very meta
so
let me just as a backdrop say i think
silicon valley in its
best
versions
shows us the bright
optimistic enabled
better future that we can have you get
glimpses of
things that might only be seen on
main street 5 10 15 20 years later so in
that sense it is a glimpse of things to
come
conversely it's also the canary in the
coal mine for new maladies for new
neuroses for new
afflictions
that are related
to
new technologies and developments and
cultural changes also if they're
associated with technology so the email
at the time
was the
email addiction
and assorted issues was the easiest to
point to
and twitter is just an example i think
you and i spoke about this some time ago
but
my understanding is that twitter
launched
officially
that same south by southwest and i
remember there being a huge
big screen tv on the ground floor of the
convention center where they had south
by southwest interactive which at the
time was really the red-headed stepchild
of the entire event it was tiny it was
so small and now it's the connective
tissue that binds everything at south by
southwest together
but at the time it's very small and you
could see all of the tweets being
published in real time in the world
on one big screen tv and you could watch
it you could watch it slowly click
through and you could see it scroll it
was incredible
and kind of crazy to think that you
could do that at that point 2007
but twitter wasn't ubiquitous social
media weren't ubiquitous in the same way
that they they are today so email at the
time
was
a clear example of a tool
that was designed for
defense purposes
if we go back to like arpanet and so on
best i can
tell
that was now being adapted to be used as
an instant messaging
tool by millions of people
and
i recall i don't know if i mentioned
this in the talk but
at the time
robert scoble was a big figure in this
corner of tech and he had said something
to me along the lines i may have only
mentioned this in later talks i don't
know if i mentioned that one but
that the only way to
receive fewer emails is to not respond
and that he had noticed when he
responded to email for every email he
responded to he received something like
1.75 email in response
and
that is the very definition of
insurmountable rights
you used the word metastasize earlier in
the conversation i think that's
very appropriate here and if you begin
to telescope out just looking at if we
take that math as roughly true for a lot
of people in some fashion it was very
clear
that
we
had either a broken tool and or
a broken approach to handling this tool
and everybody empathized especially the
people in this audience at south by
southwest i mean these are tech early
adopters
who have maybe been sort of wading
through
the briar patches
and quicksand of high volume email by
that point perhaps for a few years
longer
than the mainstream that acute pain
perhaps had not been been felt by a lot
of other people which is part of the
reason why i think the four-hour work
week really
and it was deliberate on my part also
but it really took off among
tech savvy and tech immersed knowledge
workers
in a handful of cities
first
and right i think it's because they felt
the pain most acutely
and that matches my research they're
hard to find now but i used to have
people were posting notes their notes
from your session
and
the email
it's too much
tell people you're not going to answer
except all of that elimination ideas was
just asterisked exclamation point
scroble's interview with you let's get
into the email you definitely
felt that this is where that tipping
point was happening but no one no one
was yet saying this was unsustainable my
whole theory on this is that when i went
back and did all the research on email
spread it spreads in the early 90s
because
we needed
more cost-effective asynchronous
communication it was replacing fax
machines and voicemail and it's cheaper
and it did it well and it's good for
that and then we got what you said which
was well let's just use this as the main
medium through which all collaboration
happens hyperactive hive minded back and
forth conversation that doesn't scale
that fried our brains and tech got there
first but the problem was tech was the
wrong place for that to hit first
because they're such techno
instrumentalists in that world they're
like okay it's all about user habits if
i can just get a custom vim
macro suite set up just properly right
this was the era of merlin man and inbox
zero that like if email's a problem is
because i don't have the right
setup i don't write configuration i
don't have the right processing system
for and so they were they're going at it
by saying i'll just build better tools
because the tech people
tech is quite neutral it's all about how
you use it so like we must just be using
this tool wrong but i think you're right
and i agree with that theory that no no
the whole way is uh organizations were
using emails like this is how
collaboration happened there's nothing
you could do to your inbox configuration
that was going to save you
from having to answer a lot of emails
you had to actually change how the work
happened
which is basically what a lot of what
you were preaching and maybe that's what
made it transgressive at the time or or
a release but i'm glad you had that same
reaction because that's so strongly how
i remember your talk is the email thing
just landed you know like that was a
punch that just landed and the audience
was like yes
oh yeah oh yeah now email and the idea
of autoresponders and de-risking
autoresponders and case studies of
people who'd implemented
interval based
management of email say checking every
day at 10 am and 4 pm and providing a
phone number
if they're needed more urgently etc i
mean these types of approaches and the
actual experiments and case studies
which
allowed people to
see how infrequently the worst case
scenarios manifest landed in a very very
big way and just to build on what you
said
it's very tempting to think that you can
make
surface level changes to the tools and
tactics
that already lay on top of what you're
doing and
it turns out i think
certainly in
hindsight if we look at the last 20
years since 2000
i would
imagine
that
if
what i've seen is any reflection of a
broader experience that
instead of having an inbox now you have
five crowded inboxes
you have
different messaging apps you might have
imessage you might have multiple emails
you might have
any number of other applications that
sit on the desktop or on your phone and
it's clear to me that
you really
at least i mean millions of people who
have read the four hour work week have
found it more
helpful to start with first principles
and questioning assumptions and
identifying
possible worst case scenarios how to
mitigate them and then running
experiments
a little higher up the stack if that
makes any sense or or further upstream
just to mix all my metaphors because at
the end of the day
if you have an unsustainable approach
you can window address it
with
an upgrade or an application switch but
you're not typically addressing root
causes
and i think that's why
even now since you just read it last
week i mean you can say as credibly as
anyone that
the resources in the four hour work week
are out of date and
many of the examples how to market test
how to
launch
what people would now call an mvp
have all changed but the book still sits
in the top few hundred on amazon
generally to this day somewhere in the
top thousand
and i think it's because of the
principles it's because the principles
and the stories and the pain are still
present
and can still be used or in the case of
the pain
minimized by kind of revisiting the
fundamentals
right you're saying it's not go to my pc
and tv fans
that's right that's right yeah those
those those are no longer relevant and
if this is actually a great point like
if you think the latest
app is going to save you you're just
going to have to repeat the drill six
months later 12 months later there's
very little durability to
a tactic
based or a tool-based
approach in my experience
right you're not one slack plug-in away
from productivity nirvana from nirvana
right
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
linkedin jobs small business owners
juggle 100 balls and don't have time to
interview unqualified or even under
qualified job candidates linkedin jobs
makes it easier for you to find the
people you should interview faster and
for free create a free job post in
minutes on linkedin jobs to reach the
world's largest professional network of
more than 770 million people
then add that job and the purple hashtag
hiring frame to your linkedin profile to
spread the word that you're hiring so
your network can help you find the best
applicants for the position simple tools
like screening questions make it easy to
focus on candidates with just the right
skills and experience so you can quickly
prioritize who you'd like to interview
and possibly hire it's for all these
reasons and more that small businesses
rate linkedin jobs number one in
delivering quality hires versus leading
competitors linkedin jobs helps you more
quickly find the candidates you want did
you know that every week nearly 40
million job seekers visit linkedin
post your job for free at linkedin.com
tim that's linkedin.com tim to post your
job for free terms and conditions apply
one of the things you talk about in the
for our work week is in elimination you
talk about i don't like productivity and
i think most time management is you know
in some sense a waste of time this is
smart people spending too much time
trying to be more efficient instead of
trying to be smarter about what they do
and i recently did this big piece for
the new yorker on it was called the rise
and fall of getting things done and it
was about the rise of the productivity
prawn movement which was this movement
that felt like with the right high-tech
tools and scripts and database-backed
applications you could basically make
work you could tame all your work it
would be easy an interesting thing about
that timeline is that that movement
picked up all of its speed
in the three or four years before the
four-hour workweek came out and around
the time the four-hour workweek came out
the main one of the main organs of that
which was uh merlin man's 43 folders
blog which was a really important thing
at the time oh it's hugely influential
yeah
basically not shut down but it
redirected away from i'm this isn't
going to work that's kind of the point
of this article that followed merlin's
story but it was like okay we're not
going to solve work by just having
quicksilver scripts and and kgtd like
actually we need to rethink work all of
that was concurrent so when you're
looking at productivity is not working
time management's not working
is that what you were seeing that moment
of that that brief moment of optimism
where we thought with like the right mac
configurations we can make our
overwhelming work effortless without
having to actually ask the question of
what our work is
you might not remember i mean this is a
while ago no i remember a lot of it i
think that last portion
is
true for me at least in the sense that
the cult of productivity
we have to be very careful with that
term and you've written about this i
read your recent piece actually which i
thought was very good we used to define
productivity very carefully
yes lest we become
yeah you know the greyhound chasing this
rabbit around a track not knowing why
we're there in the first place but
i think
technologists
and those who are
mesmerized by
technologists and technology
are very prone
to getting
extremely
efficient at doing things that are not
important
and sometimes sometimes they do apply to
things that are important but the thrust
of the four hour workweek i would say in
a nutshell is
what you do is more important than how
you do it
and put another way being effective
is more important than being efficient
so let's think really hard
about
the 80 20 principle otherwise known as
pareto's law
such that
if you focus on the highest leverage
things even if you [ __ ] up every which
way from sunday
you have such a margin of safety and
such a disproportionate
output for the time that you put in it's
okay
does that make sense so
if you look at
you know churchill drucker i mean a lot
of these figures
who were massively
productive by almost any definition i
mean taking naps you got like ulysses s
grant alcoholic you know it's not like
they were sitting in front of a
typewriter or dictating or active
frenetically active all the time that
was just not the case
so
yeah
yeah i agree with you and i think
anyone who has attempted to
kind of address the
malaise of overwork by adding
more tools and tricks and scripts
realizes pretty quickly that the water
is always going to fill
faster than you can bail it out with
that type of approach
at least in my experience yeah
i think that idea was very influential
for me too i got it from you i'm pretty
you know i got that from the far work
week but i thought about it recently i
wrote an essay over the summer where i
read a book about the history of all the
a lot of great scientists about the
history of science and i wrote this
essay that was saying
galileo didn't work that much and yet we
see him as being incredibly productive
but he was never he was rarely busy
that's before our work week idea i just
want to say one more thing because it's
so tangible for folks a lot of
people
don't identify with scientists or maybe
even writers but
this is true of a lot of the world's
best investors also
i mean warren buffett don't just
do something stand there instead of
don't just stand there do something and
dairy
laziness bordering on sloth i think is
how either he or munger have described
their investing approach
you don't have to do a lot
if you get a few things right right if
you really pick your targets well
okay good now that you brought it up let
me just as an aside pitch you this this
this idea i've been developing on my
podcast recently slow productivity yeah
and here's my whole concept i don't know
let's see if this makes sense
productivity depends on scale
so when you say what i want to do is
maximize what i produce on the scale of
weeks
you're going to be very very busy let's
get things moving emails going back and
forth i'm jumping on calls or what have
you but if you change the scale to years
like i want to maximize what i produce
over the next five years to be as
impressive as possible it's like a
completely different game because now
it's like i want to produce three great
things in the next five years which
means you're wednesday you might do
nothing right it's like scale so this is
my this is my new thing maybe scale the
scale at which you're talking about
producing changes the
rhythm
of what your everyday every day feels
like but this is all aspirational for me
because i have too much going on
so yeah i i love that phrasing slow
productivity or like patient
productivity is maybe another way to to
look at it and
not to
revert back to investing over and over
again but money is such a
important tangible scary alluring thing
to
people that it's useful as an instrument
when talking about some of these
principles and i read a book recently
well listen to a book called the
psychology of money by morgan hausell
and i was quite impressed by it and one
of the chapters explored
the importance of playing your own game
and not other people's games but that
entails knowing what games they are
playing so for instance if you have
momentum traders who are in very short
positions who really don't care if
let's just use an arbitrary example if
google has a higher price a year from
now but they do care they don't care
about fundamentals anything like that
free cash flow whatever they don't care
about any of that what they do care
about is sort of market sentiment or
behavior driving up the price they can
sell tomorrow or a week later and
it's important to kind of know the
motivations and the games of other
participants
because if you have a different time
horizon
your way of relating to that is totally
different
for instance like can i guess
this is not investment advice but like
can i guess
can i guess correctly whether stock's
going to go up or down by what
percentage over the next week no over
a year no probably not i mean any kind
of cataclysm could hit but
there are certain trends over time where
it's like yeah do i think there are
certain technologies that inescapably
are going to become more pervasive in a
five to ten year stretch and if i invest
in companies that are investing heavily
in those areas do i have a pretty high
degree of confidence it's going to go up
yep and that's all the homework i really
need to do
does that make sense
and similarly
with productivity
if your time horizon is like how can i
get
the most important things done over the
next five years and that's reasonably
well thought through
but you're reading interviews with
people on the cover of magazines if
that's even a thing anymore
who are in a mad sprint in a zero-sum
startup game to like dominate market
share and
do god knows what
you're playing different games they're
just different games
was that your mindset
when you moved into podcasting
like now we're doing a long game because
you had a lot going on yeah it seems
like you simplified things and at first
it must have been
the first month you're doing that
is not an empire
oh yeah the podcast well the here's i'm
not sure if this is going to be relevant
but i'll tell you the podcast came about
because the four-hour chef just about
killed me it was such a complex project
done in such
on such tight timelines
it was
one of the most grueling things i've
ever done physically very very
difficult project and
when i launch books i'm basically doing
an 80 20 analysis and looking at what is
the different channels
and forms of media that are decreasing
in influence but are thought to have
still very high influence by the
majority and thus kind of overvalued in
some fashion this could apply to paid
acquisition too and then i'm looking at
the
neglected darlings that are undervalued
in some way uncrowded in some way but
growing in importance and so podcasts i
do this every book launch and the
podcasts came out pretty uniformly as
having a massive impact this is in 2012
2011 2012 planning this so i did a lot
of podcasts for
the book release
and they had tremendous impact and i
really enjoyed the format
and
decided
that i wanted to test podcasting for i
think my commitment was six episodes
but here's the rationale the rationale
was
or rather the question that i would ask
myself is like
is there a way that i can win doing this
even if i fail
and the way that
i win doing something even if i fail is
if i develop skills
and relationships or deepen
relationships that transcend that
project as a failure does that make
sense yup scott adams writes a lot about
this really well
and in the case of the podcast i thought
to myself well i'm going to take a break
from books no matter what given the type
of books i write i do interviews i ask
questions
i would like to get better at asking
questions and navigating those
conversations
i'm going to have these types of
conversations anyway also
so why don't i determine what i think
the minimum effective dose is
for podcasting like how many episodes
would i actually have to do to start to
get better at speaking and interviewing
i was like yeah six to ten probably
great let's commit to that
and then i was off to the races and
it's become a lot more sense
but that's how it started
interesting yeah i was just i was
curious about that so that's uh i'm glad
we got that that detour
but okay so going back to
work being unsustainable
warning shot when you got this
opportunity to speak at south by
southwest 2007 at south by southwest
interactive
this was potentially a hostile crowd as
far as i can tell right because these
are silicon valley types i mean he's at
this music festival but this is where
all the khaki pants were and all the
vest were these were people who were
going after it crushing it you know
trying to get their startups turned
around so it kind of could have gone
both ways so because this was ground
center so so were you
were you worried about that or were you
you knew everyone enough people in this
world are like yeah everyone's going to
be on board with this what's the mindset
going into that crowd
the mindset was i really don't have much
to lose
in the sense that if it works
great if it doesn't work it doesn't work
and i'm right back where i started and i
felt like i knew
that crowd because i was a member of
that crowd on some level if that makes
sense
and
i also wanted to
approach it
maybe this is part of the mindset by
telling my story and describing case
studies i was
you would know better than i cause i
haven't heard it since i gave it but i
don't think i was saying you have to do
this and everyone should do
x y and z
there are certainly prescriptions like
you could do this this is what i've done
this is what so-and-so did but it was it
was really sharing a story and there was
so much common pain i knew the pain was
gonna land
i knew it was going to land because i
had also
workshopped the material
on classes
for years of technologists and now these
are undergrad and graduate students but
nonetheless i was living in silicon
valley so i was surrounded by
friends who were co-founders and people
who were using technology
so i was very highly confident that at
the very least
the various pains would be something
people would identify with
and
also maybe a little known fact
hugh forrest who i thank pretty much
every time i speak at south by southwest
gave me a shot i did not have a proper
room the talk was given in basically an
overflow room i want to say that also
acted as a mini cafeteria and there was
a cancellation there was some type of
cancellation
and
to my memory he was like hey if you
still want a shot we got a spot
you know here's this little stage
and i want to say the capacity was
something like 100
maybe 100 to 150 people somewhere in
that range
and
no one knew the hell i was and it was
packed it was packed and that had
nothing to do with me had zero to do
with me it had to do with the pain and
the
potential of some
tool kit that would help alleviate that
pain but it was standing remotely and
that
that is purely from
subject matter
the structure of the talk was
six minutes seven minutes
pain like let's get let's get into the
pain and then
relief and
you know we can radically rethink what
work is and now we'll talk through like
different ways you might do that
one of the things i picked up
re-listening to it recently too is the
other thing that seemed to land in there
was the examples you gave about
it's okay
to do things that might make someone
else his life temporarily less
convenient for some reason that really
landed like put an autoresponder and say
i'm not going to respond to you right
away
or fire a client those two things really
seem to land do you think that gets at
the pain in a pretty clear way like or
the frustration i definitely came away
with that because when i heard those two
things i remember those things landy
when i first heard your talk and they
landed whatever this is now 14 15 years
later it's okay
to basically tell some people
you have to be inconvenienced here so
there must be something going on where
like everyone could just
grab you in your time and there's a
helplessness and that frustration was
palpable when those examples really i
think those examples really got to it
for sure and it's also you know the sort
of interpretation is in the eye of the
beholder here but you know one way to
look at it would be
it's okay if you inconvenience other
people
the other way to look at it is
it is not just okay but it's imperative
that you prioritize your self-care
and if you don't
you're not going to be a player in this
game very long and if you don't
establish boundaries and
ask for what you want indicate what you
don't want
the world will be happy to program all
that for you
and
chances are it's not going to turn out
very well
so
you can sort of develop a
[Music]
what i would consider a positive
assertiveness
or you can build resentment and accrue
fatigue until you break and it's not
only those two options but
i think it's perhaps useful to think of
the two in opposition
and that definitely landed for folks and
the tools are important and i don't want
to say that the tools aren't important
but ultimately
it's asking better questions it's
testing assumptions and it's really
reorienting yourself with
different
philosophies and a different psychology
because if you don't believe it's okay
for anyone to wait
an hour or two or three or even a day or
two or three
for a response in some instances it
doesn't matter what tool you use
it just doesn't and
impatience will just swell to fill the
void if you allow it on behalf of
everyone who is being trained to be
impatient
what was the
private reception if you remember so now
you're you've given the talk standing
room only
you're socializing the parties et cetera
that makes up south by southwest you
remember what were people
talking to you about growing you about
excited about
i would say that
the vast majority
it's been a while right so to my memory
the vast majority of
the
conversations began with a confession of
some type people came up to talk about
their pain or their situation
or
the unrealistic expectations that are
made of them and how they feel
like they have digital handcuffs of one
type or another i mean it almost always
started with
some type of confession and
commiserating right because i'd been
there and done that so i wasn't an
outsider in that sense i was
a fellow patient
it's that mixing
that makes sense and yeah
people were also excited and nervous to
test things so they
were looking for reassurance that
these were experiments
worth doing with limited downside which
is always how i painted it i said what
is the i would ask questions and you've
heard this again i haven't heard the
talk and since i gave it but what is the
absolute worst case scenario if you put
up an autoresponder
are you going to be
fired
sight unseen because you created an
autoresponder
okay then you determine what you think
the worst case scenario is how could you
mitigate the risk of that downside maybe
you talk to your boss in advance maybe
you test it
only for half a day on fridays when your
boss leaves
at 3 pm and you can get to see how
co-workers respond to it and then
how would you sort of reverse the damage
if the worst case scenario comes through
well you take the autoresponder down
what is the residual damage of that
really and if the damage is
containable if it's finite
and you look at the potential upside of
what it could mean to you if it works
that is a gamble worth taking
right it's just an asymmetric
bet
and so i really tried to frame it that
way i was like look i'm not saying
that anyone should commit to doing these
things forever right because a lot of
the concerns and the pushback would be
like well what if this what if that what
if all these scenarios
i can't account for all the scenarios
but i do know that in my own life and in
the life of the people who served as
case studies
a short test
24 hours 48 hours is very
valuable because it provides you with
more information and it either confirms
or questions
a lot of the fears associated the
anxieties associated with it
so a lot of the conversations were
around that and people got right to it i
mean south by southwest lasts a while
so there were people who began to test
autoresponders the next day
and so people then started coming up to
me
to
share their kind of hallelujah
i thought all these horrible things were
going to happen and none of them
happened
at the same conference at the same
conference i mean i think
that's a very important point that
the freedom to experiment is the meta
value like in other words like the book
and your talk is a microcosm of the book
first lays out here's this pain that
wasn't being articulated
and so people say thank you right no
one's articulating this they're all
saying god you know get after it and
then the second part is
you have a lot more options than you
think you can even be relatively radical
in re-engineering what work means
go out there and try things
and then the book had specific
things to try
but am i paraphrasing or summarizing the
reaction how you were thinking properly
when you were saying it's not that
you have to build a particular automated
muse that uses va's in this very
particular way it's you should be doing
that type of experiment like be willing
to say well what if i did this let me
try this and you and you might not end
up selling french sailor shirts
but you can don't forget about that
yeah yeah yeah
but you could almost certainly end up
with a much
better work configuration might look
much different it might the person who
always comes to mind and i won't use his
name because i didn't ask him permission
he's a common friend of ours and was
really big you know on your book when it
came out i met up with him at some point
it was 2008
in rio
and i was there presenting a paper to
computer science conference he was there
for carnival because he had been he's a
lifestyle designer and when i first met
up with him he was showing me okay i've
written this
code it was like very inline
specifically with the examples in the
book it goes through the google adwords
automatically finds like what
underperforming you know value adwords i
click this button and it automatically
sends a email to my my va's in the
philippines who are good english
speakers who then write 25 articles on
this topic and put it on hubspot so we
can get a high price for these
he wanted you know very very automated
and then i met up with him a couple
years later
and
what he was doing was much more
sustainable he was a computer program
he's like you know i found that i'm
working remotely hourly but for a
european company and i'm getting paid in
euros and i'm living mainly in south
america and there's a great geo
arbitrage going on there and it was
this spirit of rethink your work life
you know his first attempt was let me
exactly follow one of the examples in
the book and then where he ended up was
actually i'm getting mobility i'm
getting geo arbitrage there's bigger
concepts and then he ended up going to
an incubator and doing a startup because
he had time to think about things and
what he wanted to do and anyway so that
to me that always summarized the point
you're making there
that
you can do radical things that are
different than the thing just very
unsustainable now
but you have to go take action
experiment and that's okay and even if
some people get mad that's okay but
there's a wide variety and especially as
time changes and tech changes and like
let's say today people are not
incredibly nervous about asking for a
remote work arrangement but when that
book came out that was incredibly
avant-garde you know so the times have
changed yeah but that general principle
approaches that applies even two years
ago a lot of people would still
relate to
remote work very differently than they
do today but both as employers and
employees and i want to take if it's
okay with you just take a step back for
a second
because
the point you made about
time scale
and
how you think about say productivity
it leads me to
want to also just
mention at the very least that
the four hour work week
started with
some overarching kind of macro
principles and
the
definition
section right there's the definition
elimination automation liberation all
that
the definition section
the purpose of that was to
uncover
perhaps unexamined assumptions like
these invisible scripts that are running
a lot of art decisions and long-term
planning
and to question them and then to offer
alternatives
so for instance taking a very close look
at what i called in the book the
deferred life plan right the deferred
life plan which is this
sort of slave save retire
i will redeem my
decades of work for this sort of utopian
vision of
leisure in my older years
and
that will work for me and be great
has sort of dozens of unexamined
assumptions inside of it and
then offering alternatives like many
retirements instead of distributing
retirement throughout life since long
life is not guaranteed and there are all
sorts of other issues with assuming
you'll have
enough for retirement with no income etc
there are others that i'm just going to
mention because they may be
interesting to take a closer look at
one would also be and this is very
relevant now that
well two things one is that there's
absolute and then
relative income so determining how much
you make per hour is actually quite
important in the sense that it's easy to
say so and so it makes two hundred
thousand dollars a year someone so makes
seventy five thousand dollars a year
another person makes five hundred
thousand dollars a year
therefore the last example is the most
successful and no doubt they have
the
greatest sort of lifestyle output
for
what they make but the lifestyle
or life value of
each unit each dollar is really
dependent on
other factors and to what degree you
control them the where with whom how etc
determines a lot of that and which is
part of the reason that
geo arbitrage or geo arb was another
thing that was
i don't know if it was put on the map
but it was definitely
kind of thrust into the zeitgeist
by readers of this book the idea that
you can
geo arbitrage which you can do in a
single country or even a single state
right it doesn't have to be scattering
different
income and expenses around the world it
could be
you know you've you've gone through
covid you've lived in manhattan you
decided this makes no sense to escape
the city you went to
new jersey or long island or connecticut
or who knows where right upstate new
york you realize you prefer that quality
of life and that you can get you know
four times the sort of value for money
in in certain locations even just within
a radius of a few hours
i just think the definition
section is super
super important we don't have to dwell
on it but i just wanted to mention some
of like these overarching
approaches to deconstructing assumptions
that underlie a lot of our decision
making
let's pull on that thread
in particular the thread about
today this message was 15 years ago
work is unsustainable
be
willing to consider radical changes to
what work is and what role it plays in
your life there's the mystery of why
that warning shot was somewhat
ignored in the semi-immediate aftermath
which i'll get back to in a second but
we fast forward to today especially
covid post pandemic
as someone who's writing about these
topics right now
this is exactly what's on everyone's
mind
this book
and what you're talking about everyone
is going through not everyone but
there's a very large fraction of let's
say remote capable knowledge workers who
who had severe disruption in what their
day-to-day life was like due to the
pandemic who are going through the
thinking you mentioned before you're
seeing the book is
catching not catching a new wave it's
always sold well but it's finding an
audience now a new audience
it's never really stopped
but i would imagine
i would have to imagine it's finding a
new audience i mean a friend of mine old
friend sent me a photograph
from austin he said oh this makes me
happy and he said it was a photograph of
a young guy probably late 20s
reading
four-hour work week the only hardcover
addition
or i should say the latest hardcover
edition that exists which is the 2009
expanded and updated edition
right so
11 or 12 years later
postcovid
this is still finding
an audience and it's finding new
audiences i think in part because
there were early adopters for this book
and there were
people who really
ran the tests and did the experiments in
the book
and then there was also of course it's
called the four-hour workweek there was
a lot of dismissing it
based on the title
even though i mean on some level it's
really about maximizing per hour output
right on some level it's about that but
for the title
because of how popular it became
in the subsequent
year you know it's on the new york times
bestseller list i want to say for
i could get you the exact duration but
like four and a half years five years
straight or something like that and
it became part of the pop cultural
conversation
and
i think that
there are many many i mean there have to
be at this point just given the exposure
of the book millions of people who have
seen the book they've heard about the
book and they concluded this will never
work
this can never work for me
and then all of a sudden you know this
discussion of time and mobility which is
the centerpiece of the four-hour work
week
has been pushed to the forefront of
everyone's mind through this gigantic
experiment called covet 19.
and all of a sudden people who thought
they wanted to be in an office people
who thought they wanted to work in a
certain way
after
having experienced alternatives are
saying wait a second
i actually don't want to go back to the
office
how do i figure this out
and
they're also
i don't want to say risks but
challenges in working remotely in
feeling like you have and developing
community when you are fully distributed
and these problems existed
certainly
when the four-hour workweek was
initially released they still exist so i
feel like we are still in the honeymoon
phase of remote work
for millions of people
they think they found the promised land
but i don't think they have experienced
some of the harder aspects like the
filling the void chapter in four hour
work week talks about this right so
i think for a lot of these reasons and
more
the book has definitely seen a new
resurgence of interest yeah why in the
interim it's a mystery that
i'm curious about in the interim between
when it first hits work is unsustainable
you should try radical new things
in the interim the over time the book in
pop culture beyond people who are
directly engaged with the book got
associated with something different and
i mentioned this to you via email but i
think about 2011
the office brings up the book daryl
brings up the book the character dale
in the office and by that point in 2011
when he's bringing up this book it has
nothing to do with work being
unsustainable and radically rethinking
work it is all just how do i be more
hyper productive
which is almost the opposite of what the
book is about and i bet that for a lot
of people who the book was on their
radar but they didn't engage with the
book
that's for a lot of people became
associated with like being hyper
productive by using you sort of
radically inventive in the systems you
use
for the purpose of getting more done
which is not what the book was about and
so this is sort of this mystery to me is
that this big warning shot was happening
we feel it today huge yeah works not
sustainable we need to re-change it but
in between somehow that warning shot for
a lot of people got changed to um how
can we use tech and innovative systems
to get even more done yeah that's a damn
fine question you know the four hour
work week became and you know i didn't
mind i thought it was kind of funny
this
yeah sort of pop culture productivity
novel that word again novel
novelty yeah in a way right so you so it
shows up on the office or the cast
from well supposedly the cast i mean
it's probably a bunch of ghost writers
but from it's always sunny in
philadelphia wrote a book called the
seven secrets of awakening the highly
effective four-hour giant today right so
you can see
what that is
and
i would love to hear your theory for why
this is but i think it's deeply deeply
uncomfortable
and it can be deeply deeply challenging
to really
question the assumptions and plans that
are
the underpinning for much of your
existence
your waking existence i think it's very
uncomfortable
and it's not as cleanly
measurable perhaps as
installing a new chrome plug-in that
helps you do a b and c and i i cleared
17 more email in the last hour that type
of trackability
and that type of
countability
is really alluring
so the productivity porn like real porn
is highly addictive and highly
distracting
and
as new
technical doodads and
applications and
approaches surfaced even if they're old
approaches that are being reinvented
right using note cards or index cards
for various things it's a very graspable
appealing novelty that i think almost
everyone gravitates towards you know
it's not surprising to me that the four
hour work week became
a representation of
a collection of productivity
tricks or techniques or technologies
because it did include that in fairness
but
i think that what is unfortunate
but not surprising is that the for our
work we sort of treated like a tool kit
and a bunch of construction materials
but used without the blueprint
and the approach and the guiding design
principles that are explored in the
first
say two sections especially
those two things right divorced where in
my mind the blueprints and the design
principles
those are the most valuable and most
important piece and then the tools those
are all going to change over time and i
expect them to change over time that's
what i've
observed
did you observe people
doing that you know just looking at the
hacks and not or was it the
the perception of the people who weren't
reading the book but just this is what i
think it is
because of course you're around this
crowd a lot more yeah i think it's more
the latter the book is written in a way
if you start at page one you cannot get
around the sort of philosophical resets
and questioning of assumptions and
design principles you can't get 100
yeah
but if
you are
reading a blog post that is supposedly a
summary of the four-hour work week or
you are
reading any number of books that
followed the 4-hour workweek which were
intended to kind of capitalize on
that wave of popularity
they focused
almost without exception on
the tools and the tricks and the latest
websites and the best virtual assistant
services and so on
again not to say those don't have value
they do have value but
without the underlying frameworks and
principles
i don't think you end up solving many
problems and in fact i think you can end
up creating a lot of new problems
well and maybe some of that was i mean
you're 100 right because i just reread
the book
there's no other way to interpret the
book if you read it there's no other way
to interpret it then this is
unsustainable you know you have to craft
the life that emphasizes the other
currencies that are important
this is what the good life is built on
oh now let's talk about
how you might do it and part of this as
i have two theories i'll tell you part
of this i think is
don't underestimate the degree to which
the
the way you did talk about the systems
when you got there was so new and
compelling that it almost opened up a
new
genre and tone in productivity there was
a i don't quite know how to
articulate it but there was a precision
and a
brashness to you know it was like very
declarative and precise and it's kind of
hard to articulate but the way you would
talk about
and the va should do this and we should
and don't do it for this i can't do it
justice but it's very compelling in
itself so i think you might have
introduced a
stylistic approach to giving advice
that itself could be
separated yeah know from the context
right because that's a great it was a
it's a very compelling but it's very
compelling the book is very compelling
beyond the content so there's yeah
there's something in in that tone but
then the other thing is i i think and i
talked when we last talked kind of i was
bringing this up to you is that i've
been covering recently i'm very
interested in the the anti-productivity
movement and it's very powerful right
now
and i'm taken by the degree to which
when you read people
who are in this movement
the way they characterize what is
popular in productivity and type
management is invented
it's fabricated like when they talk
about like what productivity books are
out there right now they will say it's
like yeah it's all about trying to get
60 things done and find more time in
your day to get things done and so i go
over to okay
time management in amazon let's look at
the best seller list right what are the
commonly the top three books there it
it's usually shifting back and forth
between four hour work week
my 2016 book deep work
and greg mcewen's 2015 book essentialism
all of these books are about working
less getting away from distraction
getting away from busyness trying to
like get the things that are more
meaningful i mean you have to go down
pretty far i mean david allen shows up
pretty early but i think he's
misinterpreted i think he's more about i
hate the fact we have so much to do but
let's at least try to tame it so we
don't go insane right so you can't
really interpret him as pushing for
overwork i can't find on the list of
best-selling time management books right
now anything yeah that is
how do we get more done i think like the
last book like that that just straight
up lionized that was maybe hyper
productivity from eight years ago or
something like this and so that that
also seems to be effect it's going on is
that for people who
are characterizing for our work week or
any of these books or characterizing me
or other people in the genre who aren't
engaged in the books
they have just projected this whole
fabricated world where
productivity we're all frederick winslow
taylor and we have stopwatches
and we're you know twirling our
mustaches and trying to trying to get
people to move back and forth between if
you put your keyboard over here you can
type faster move your mouse faster and
whatever so i don't know what that means
but it seems to be true that there is a
fabricated world of what productivity
literature is
and nothing like that has been popular
in
30 years
yeah i think i think the narrative
this is true for a lot of things there's
a delay in the narrative how we think
about ourselves how we
perceive the world around us what we
think is popular
is informed by our realities but there's
kind of a lag time
and the durability to
narratives if that makes any sense so if
you grow up with like hyperinflation you
have a certain story around that like
you're going to continue to have that
story
even beyond hyperinflation
for a period of time might even affect
your behavior for the rest of your life
who knows and i think that
for a lot of people who are commenting
on what they would consider productivity
books or time management books
they have all the biases that you would
expect right they have privacy recency
they've got any number of other things
at play
i think
for many people who
grew up in the
say
mid to late but not grow up
professionally came up in the mid to
late
2000s
or actually it's not even the end it's
not even that long it would be like the
first like 2000
to
2010 maybe
things seem to be pretty saturated with
that kind of advice not necessarily in
the form of books but certainly online
there was a lot of productivity porn and
you know i was a beneficiary of that so
i can't slam it too hard on some level
but
i think
that type of
highly prescriptive hyper productivity
instructional material has kind of lost
its luster
for most people i would say
so optimistically then and so i know
we're running short on time so i'll give
my optimistic take and you can see if
you share my optimism here's the
optimistic storyline then of for our
work week and today
is 2007
book comes out
the way we're working is becoming
unsustainable be willing to
consider radical alternatives
it was aimed at for the tech crowd that
was ahead of the trend onto
unsustainability it landed very
powerfully the people who encountered it
said yeah this is absolutely right
it's taken 15 years to get to but the
wider world around it was not quite
ready for that yet they were still we're
like look we're still doing
we still believe that maybe hardcore
productivity and systems and if we just
have the right plan planner that we can
solve this problem we get the 2021 we
get the pandemic to help accelerate this
now
knowledge work writ large is like that
300 people in that overcrowded converted
cafeteria in 2007 they now recognize
things are unsustainable they're now
really open to the idea of maybe
radically new things are
available that your book was a warning
shot
we might have ignored it for a little
while and by we i mean the people who
didn't directly encounter it which it
was a large people but now we're hearing
the echoes of that warning start
reverberating because what you are
warning about we're all there that you
were 15 years ahead of your time am i
optimistic there or is that possible
i mean that sounds plausible for sure i
certainly
what i saw and experienced other people
saw and experienced
i just happened to be the one of many
who could have written this book who sat
down after looking for this book for
myself
to write the book i couldn't find
and i think
that a lot of the
challenges
discussed
in the four-hour work week have only
compounded
and
you know if compounding is the
eighth
sort of greatest wonder of the world
then it's remarkable and terrifying what
that can become so
i do think i agree with you that it's
you know same same but 10x same same but
100x same same 1000x
and instead of one inbox we now have 14.
it's
it's clear to me and maybe this will
always be the case but that
a lot of what we consider work is just
simply not working and
it's never been more important to ensure
that we are not getting really good at
doing things that should not be done in
the first place
and optimistically also we've never in a
sense had more options the technology
has never been better
the flexibility with remote work
arrangements have never been better so
the tools and options
and unorthodox
career and life choices that are
available
now have never been available to more
people in my opinion
so i know we're we're at the 90 minute
mark i promise so i'll just i'll just
conclude by saying when i first read
that book or listen to it i guess it was
in
april
2007 i had that instinct that there's
something prophetic about this in the
sense that this is picking up on bigger
trends that are going to be very
important and a lot of thinking a lot of
things are going to be based on for a
long time to come and at least it's my
sentiment that that
15 years later i think that was uh that
was true i'm glad you put those ideas
out there when you did thanks cal i
really appreciate that and
really admire the work that you do and
the thinking that you do behind the work
that you put out really i'm a big fan so
thank you for
taking the time to to have the chat also
and well thank you tim
hey guys this is tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that i send out every friday to
share the coolest things i've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles and reading books i'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that gets sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcast guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then i test them and then i share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about
if you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.blog friday type that into your
browser tim.log slash friday drop in
your email and you'll get the very next
one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement i've been asked this for
years the answer is invariably ag-1 by
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance so you can cover
your bases if you're traveling if you're
just busy you're not sure if your meals
or where they should be it covers your
bases i've recommended it
since the 4 hour body which was god eons
ago 2010 and i did not get paid to do so
with approximately 75 vitamins minerals
and whole foods source ingredients
you'll be hard-pressed to find a more
nutrient-dense formula on the market it
has a multivitamin multimineral greens
complex probiotics and prebiotics for
gut health and immunity formula
digestive enzymes and adaptogens
you get the idea it is very very
comprehensive and i do my best of course
to focus on nutrient dense proper meals
but sometimes you're busy sometimes
you're traveling sometimes you just want
to make sure
that you're getting what you need ag-1
makes it easy to get a lot of nutrition
when whole foods aren't readily
available it's also nsf certified for
sport making it safe for competitive
athletes as what's on the label is in
the powder it's the ultimate all-in-one
nutritional supplement bundle in one
easy scoop right now athletic greens is
giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
this episode is brought to you by fiori
clothing spelled v-u-o-r-i
fiore i've been wearing
fiori at least one item per day for the
last few months and
you can use it for everything it's
performance apparel
but it can be used for working out it
can be used for going out to dinner at
least in my case i feel very comfortable
with it super comfortable super stylish
and i just want to read something that
one of my employees said she is an
athlete she is quite technical although
she would never say that i asked her if
she had ever used or heard of biore and
this was her response i do love their
stuff been using them for about a year i
think i found them at rei first for my
partner t-shirts that are super soft but
somehow last as he's hard on stuff and
then i got into the super soft cotton
yoga pants and jogger sweatpants i live
in them and they too have lasted they're
stylish enough i can wear them out and
about the material is just super soft
and durable i just got their clementine
running shorts for summer and love them
the brand seems pretty popular
constantly sold out in closing and i'm
abbreviating here but in closing with
the exception of when i need technical
outdoor gear they're the only brand i've
bought in the last year or so for yoga
running loungewear that lasts and that i
think look good also
i like the discrete logo so that gives
you some idea that was not intended for
the sponsor read that was just her
response via text viori again spelled
v-u-o-r-i
is designed for maximum comfort and
versatility you can wear it running you
can wear their stuff training doing yoga
lounging weekend errands or in my case
again going out to dinner it really
doesn't matter what you're doing their
clothing is so comfortable
and uh looks so good and it's it's
non-offensive you don't have a huge
brand logo on your face you'll just want
to be in them all the time and my
girlfriend and i have been wearing them
for the last few months they're men's
core short kore the most comfortable
lined athletic short is your one short
for every sport i've been using it for
kettlebell swings for runs you name it
the banks short this is their go to land
to see short is the ultimate versatility
it's made from recycled plastic bottles
and what i'm wearing right now
which i had to pick one to recommend to
folks out there or at least to men out
there is the ponto performance pant and
you'll find these at the link i'm going
to give you guys you can check out what
i'm talking about but i'm wearing them
right now they're thin performance
sweatpants but that doesn't do them
justice so you got to check it out ponto
ponto performance pant for you ladies
the women's performance jogger is the
softest jaw girl you'll ever own
fiore isn't just an investment in your
clothing it's an investment in your
happiness and for you my dear listeners
they're offering 20 off your first
purchase so get yourself some of the
most comfortable and versatile clothing
on the planet
it's super popular a lot of my friends
have now noticed are wearing this
and
so much yori clothing dot com forward
slash tim that's v u o r i clothing dot
com slash tim not only will you receive
20 off your first purchase but you'll
also enjoy free shipping on any us
orders over 75 dollars and free returns
so check it out fioreclothing.com
tim that's v-u-o-r-i clothing dot com
slash tim and discover the versatility
of the ore clothing
[Applause]
you